The joe rogan experience.
What so what do you think about?
The Washington Post is owned by Jeff Bezos,
the richest guy in the world handy.
Fascinating.
And he sits on a Pentagon board and he has a $600 million deal with the CIA and
he runs the paper of $600 million deal with the CIA.
Yeah.
Which is like something home twice as well.
Amazon Alexis doing so he's on Alexis just gathering up information on
everything you do.
Yes,
it is shit out of me.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's not good.
Jamie and I were just talking about that new apple home thing,
which has the most amazing microphones.
Jamie was saying that while the music is blaring,
you could say,
Hey Siri,
just real quiet.
which suck my Dick.
Seriously.
I can't do that sir.
Details about the CIA's deal with Amazon $600 million computing cloud built by
an outside company is a radical departure from the risk averse intelligence
community.
Now they're in bed with the Washington Post or a Jeff Bezos.
Now he also sits on a Pentagon board.
He's got so much money.
He's fascinating to me because like what?
How do you keep going when you have 105 billion?
Like what's getting up in the morning?
So he's a megalomaniac,
right?
How do you accumulate more wealth than any person in the history of the world?
That means kings,
Queens.
That's not necessarily true.
The reason why is we don't count the same kind of money that the oligarchs have.
Like especially people that,
first of all,
people have said that it's very possible that Putin is the richest man alive
because they,
they're not counting how much money Putin has stolen from all the various
companies,
that he's just sort of absorbed and that he owns all that stuff.
But also we don't count all these kings and these princes in the Middle East,
they're,
they're not publicly,
they're not public people.
So,
so let's say if all the people we can count,
he's the richest guy,
a billionaire friend of mine who's a legitimate billionaire,
told me that it's entirely possible that some of these guys are trillionaires
some of these Middle Eastern guys.
He's like,
you've never seen wealth.
Life is.
It's insane in,
do you know in the United Arab Emirates,
they make it rain every week.
Once a week.
They make it rain.
I mean,
they see the clouds really get rain.
Yeah,
because they're in the desert and they're like,
Eh,
I don't like this.
Or like a terrain.
So they fucking put all that shit that they have to put into the sky to make it
rain,
which they've been doing forever.
Cloud seeding,
but insanely expensive.
But they do it once a week.
So 52 times a year at rains there.
So what do you see?
You see a problem with the richest guy in the world owning the political paper
of note and being in bed with the CIA and he's on a Pentagon board.
Yeah,
no,
it's all spooky.
It's like some kind of Orwellian fucking nightmare.
Then we've got so much money and you can't criticize him in the paper.
They won't let their,
you know,
the people who write for that paper aren't going to fucking great session,
post duck can't write anything bad about it.
They're not going to write the,
wouldn't imagine they would even dare.
One guy wrote something bad about Amazon and the Huffington Post,
he got disciplined.
There was a guy who was a writer for the Washington Post,
wrote something in the Huffington Post that was critical of the Amazon and he
got disciplined at the Washington Post for doing that.
So that's the world we live in.
And then we have the government.
And if you ever tried to tell her about a crime inside the government,
then the government would use the espionage act to correct on you.
So we're,
again,
we're living in oligarchic Joe,
we are,
democracy has already been taken from us.
So you know that this isn't a democracy.
They've done studies.
This is provable.
The thing about the,
from the Huffington post to derail this,
but was it valid?
Was it,
yeah,
the self criticism,
was it about,
he criticized about how Jeff Basil's treats his workers.
Oh,
okay.
That has been an open area of discussion that they,
I've talked to someone who actually worked there and they were saying that they
get like a countdown.
So say an order comes in,
they literally have like a countdown on their tablet and the countdown says,
you know,
like,
I don't know what the net amount of time is,
but you have to run and find that fucking product and get it in the box and get
it shipped out inside a very small window of time.
He goes,
so I'm literally running.
I go,
you run?
He goes,
yeah,
you literally run because if you don't meet your countdown,
he goes,
you can only get away with that for a certain amount of times.
Then you get in real trouble.
So they also have these new things,
the risks to bands that they've just developed a shock.
You like a shock,
you know where you serious?
Yeah,
I was joking.
They vibe,
they just fucking shot.
He'll pull it up.
They,
but they'll vibrate and if you're,
if you're,
if you're moving the wrong way,
it will shock you back.
It'll shock you back to the right.
It hurt or is it like if you ever been to her new Cadillac?
Yeah.
Either new Cadillacs,
if you,
if you go too close to the side,
it gives you an example of subs,
gives you like a little feeling Amazon pet,
which bands designed to track and tracking steer employees movements.
So Jeff Bezos,
it's been reported it,
which is true,
is that he would,
uh,
rather it's not running run.
Well,
you my shit that day.
So now there's plenty,
there's,
there's a couple different fixes for this.
The problem of this robots,
uh,
one of them would be a unions,
right?
So I'm like,
my whole thing is,
you know,
why can't we unionize Amazon?
Why can't we use a Nice Walmart?
I know they make it hard.
Walmart literally shut down their meat.
Meatpacking in Texas because of the meatpacking group.
They unionized in Texas.
They fuck it.
We're not going to sell meat anymore in Texas.
That's how we'll fuck over the union.
So,
but we got to figure out a way to get unions.
And there was another thing,
you know,
Teddy Roosevelt was a trust buster,
which was that he was a monopoly buster.
You know,
50% of all online purchases go through amazon.com in the United States,
50% yeah.
You know,
51% of households in America have Amazon prime.
Only 49% have a landline.
So more people have Amazon prime in the United States then have a fucking land
line.
So why is that real?
So Ted,
Teddy Roosevelt would come along and go,
we've got to break this company up.
Wow.
He would say,
this is aunt.
But first,
first of all,
Jeff Bezos,
because he owns the paper,
he got the Trump was right when he said he,
he's there to get the tax in his favor because he was able to go around and
hollow out economies,
a main street in little small towns all around because he didn't have to pay
taxes,
income tax,
and for Amazon.
And so the brick and mortar places did,
he closed them down by undercutting them.
Right?
Because he,
and now he's opening up brick and mortar stores,
he closed out all the Barnes and nobles and the borders books,
and now he's opening up Amazon bookstores.
Did you know that?
So 64 [inaudible] 64 there you go.
I would see 40 even up higher than,
than from when I looked.
I have Amazon prime now.
How many of those people use it for television?
This is my question because I know that Amazon started to make apparently some
very good shows,
but I don't hear anybody talking about watching them.
Okay.